ils l'ont attendu longtemps au frais la
faute au brouillard mais l'atmosphère
s'est vite réchauffé une visite
présidentielle c'est comme un sprint une
fois le ruban coupé 45 minutes top
chrono pour saisir l'essentiel la
substantifique moelle d'un musée
revisité emmanuel macron cela serait
pourtant presque aller à musarder le
moment fraude l'intime le nouveau
ministre de la culture après si c'est un
bijou c'est véritablement une chance
pour ce territoire pour la ville de
besançon pour le département et la
région d'avoir un tel musée qui est on
peut le dire fait partie des grands
musées français le président pose sa
griffe puis vient l'heure du bain d'une
foule d'invités triés sur le volet et le
grand oral protocolaire d'élus combler
est pas peu fier l' ouverture de ce
musée dit bien haut dans la modernité de
notre temps c'est essentiel proximité il
faut avoir aussi avec la culture on voit
bien que des fois la culture peut être
une variable d'ajustement dans des
budgets qui sont contraints nous n'avons
pas voulu que la culture soit variable
d'ajustement
nous avons tenu notre engagement non
seulement le budget de la culture n'a
pas bougé mais il a augmenté à son tour
emmanuel macron vente le lieu les
collections le trésor encyclopédique de
sensibilité ce flambeau des esprits qui
veut emblématique
nous avons aujourd'hui à inventer penser
ensemble une nouvelle politique
culturelle qui sur les territoires
réinventera des dynamiques propres et
reposera sur cette ambition tout à la
fois de l'accès de l'émancipation de
tous les publics par l'art et la
revitalisation de la créativité
encouragé par temps d'ouverture
culturelle la présidente du département
tente sa chance après tout courbet aura
bientôt 200 ans le 10 juin jour
anniversaire aura lieu l'inauguration
d'une exposition
exceptionnel au musée départemental
d'ornans yan pei ming face à pour b je
profite d'ailleurs de cette occasion
pour vous inviter monsieur le président
de la république
l'invitation est lancée le président
reparti le sprint s'achève besançon et
son musée sont rendus aux bisontins